[Music]
what has it been like being back with
the Avengers
oh it's been cool man you know the great
thing about the being a part of the
Marvel franchise is we all realize how
lucky we are and it's like a little
family you know it's like the first day
of school when you come back and then by
the end of the shoot you want to kill
everybody so you're happy summers coming
but it's fun it's fun I mean the Russos
keep the energy on the set up they're
very good people they're very good with
people and with actors so they they
really put us in a position to win I
mean this one no it has to be like
herding cats well this one this one is
hilarious I would I would never want
this job as a director or ad or anybody
off camera because we are the rowdiest
bunch of actors you've ever seen it's
funny it's really like elementary school
you know they're like 64 Marvel
characters in this yeah
and that's was taken so long because
they know they can't have us all on set
the maximum they can have is six because
if they add a seven person came over we
won't we won't get anything done you
won't give anything if Ruffalo alone is
like 17 people everything that's it you
put him and cheetah together is over
with no we just how all of our
personalities click and all we do there
no insecurities there no shortcomings
we're all confident and happy in our
careers so we just make fun of each
other and you know right before the
camera rolls cheetah we'll say something
a Ruffalo do something or you know
Scarlett will say something and
everybody will just bust out laughing so
we have to start over again
and that's kind of how almost a decade
yeah yeah for me it's been five years
yeah yes yes it is it is we've like seen
babies born we've seen like every we've
seen all of us become our own adults so
so it's cool it's just really fun how
many of the 64 Marvel characters in this
can you name in 30 seconds
let's see Wow
Okin Hulk Thanos Thor spider-man Iron
Man war machine ant-man wasp so well
Black Widow Captain America you did
better than anybody I really yes yes
it's hard everybody else has failed
miserable it's hard like if I can
describe the spandex off top easily it's
just the names of the characters and
then you have to realize what characters
you're allowed to say and what
characters you don't want to talk to me
about trailer village for this thing
because they posted a shot right and it
was like no other trailer village that
I've never seen it's a trailer park like
if we break out barbecue grills it's a
trailer park
it's literally like it's it's yeah it's
a city it's massive
we as it we have what is it over a
hundred trailers in base camp and half
of those are our DJs oh all of them all
of us are in tents on the other side he
just has his own little town but no it's
it's massive it is I've never seen
anything like it it looks like when you
go to the Super Bowl and all of the
trailers outside that's what it looks
like yes it's like constant tailgating
and I don't know how they find like if
you're another movie in Atlanta I feel
sorry for you okay you can't get
trailers you can't get cable you can get
crew you can't get it it's all right
here done on the world out right here so
it sucks to be you so there's been a lot
to talk about um Falcon and Winter
Soldier and how you guys just click so
so well is so naturally he Sebastian was
really funny about this but what would
you think about a spin-off with you - oh
you know what Sebastian is a damn good
actor and he's a damn good friend so I
think our relationship it realistic us
he Chris and I our relationship kind of
works really well because there's a
mutual respect and so a spin-off would
be great but
it would be like Nick Nolte and Eddie
Murphy in 48 hours that would be our
spin-off we would it would end up with
us just beating the crap out of each
other three or four times I know it I
know it I feel Scarlett's been so
excited to have you know more females on
set this time around to balance out all
the testosterone well I think the
females have a little bit more
testosterone than the do like we sit
around with our protein shakes and like
talk politics and they're over there
doing kicks and punches and I mean
they're way more in shape than we are
yeah there's some tough ladies on this
movie we we're more on the elizabeth
Olsen side relax little eucalyptus
leaves relax and and they're over there
just throwing each other around goes
hardest out of all of you guys in the
gym you know what's weird we've never
all been in a gym together if there's a
gym big enough bodies and egos and I
think if all of us are in the gym
somebody would get hurt definitely oh
you're doing 225 put another quarter on
there I mean it would be I know at least
that would be me because I'm I go very
I'm very competitive in the gym you buff
up for these yeah yeah I'm very very
competitive what's your regiment
um is more of a full-body thing I do a
lot of cardio high intensity
weightlifting so I my trainer actually
is the spring trainer for the New
Orleans Saints
so all this summer all this spring and
summer I was working out with the Saints
before the season started so I was able
to put on a comical amount of muscle I
mean a comical amount cuz when I workout
by myself I'm like you know the arms are
good I feel pretty good you work out
with these dudes and they're in full
sweat suits
covered in garbage bags and working out
no gloves no gloves and needles make fun
of me because I wear gloves but my hands
are very nice that's right look at that
skin yeah I mean
he literally aloe vera lotions all day
new the silk that's what they call me
that's why they call me chocolate silk
that's how you told you that well I just
knew it's a natural thing you know silk
the almond milk company named a whole
line of their products after me I don't
I don't doubt it
I'm doing the commercials with the
Superbowl that's that's me a Sebastian's
new campaign you have the chocolate silk
and the vanilla silk almond milk we're a
protein-packed
cutter check I'm going to Maya why do
you fans of this franchise go bananas
over these things what do you want them
to feel with this particular one
well these Avengers 3 is gonna be very
different and they're gonna be a lot of
shocking moments and I think the fans
are gonna get more than they expect out
of this movie from all the characters I
think this is the most human of the
Avengers movies of all the Marvel movies
so I think you'll be you'll be really
surprised to see how how normal these
superheroes can be and everybody's
coming in The Avengers are kind of
fractured right but you know you have to
be a team to get it done
so what are we going to see well I mean
right now we're kind of like the
Cleveland Cavaliers you have LeBron
James you have Kyrie Irving you have
Kevin Love the new Larry Bird and it
just it hurts because we're so fractured
and once we come together magic I think
we can win four games in a row and take
home the title
you think it's gonna happen just said it
I just said it all the way with LBJ I
just said speculating LeBron might go to
LA okay I don't LA he's done LeBron is
not going Elia I see him going to the
Knicks and playing with Carmelo before
he goes to LA but they got to get rid of
Phil Jackson that because God did that
because
an amount of passion a so from here tell
me what your next thing is where you
going next well my friend and I just are
doing this movie here in Atlanta this
summer there's a lot of flying in this
know like yes there is whose idea was
that because I'm not happy about that
Falcon can walk you see Falcons walking
all the time I was recently in Dubai
there Falcons everywhere you know what
they're doing
walking they're just chilling out
walking down the street this Falcon has
legs this Falcon has great legs I'm not
trying to brag but I maxed out a 415
squat press the other day that wasn't on
a machine that was just me with a bar
bent across my shoulders stop speak
that's for 13 that's like right there
these are the thighs of a guy so you
need to be walking things I need to be
walking it hurts my self-esteem to be
flying like a stunt man get up there as
much as you want so I'm glad you said
that because I wasn't supposed to be
doing this I'll put in my contract no
more flying and I have an amazing stunt
man like literally you should be
interviewing my stunt man because I suck
at everything that's Falcon and he
didn't do it they were like no he's not
here today well where is he yeah what
happened yeah not so great a stuntman
anymore he just got knocked down a page
yeah he just and then they took this
dude and airbrushed him to look like me
very weird but you know it worked out it
worked out well I cannot wait to see it
in the finished product it's gonna be
amazing
it's a good time it's a very very
interesting storyline that witch that
we've chosen to tell it's like I said it
just it gives her humanity to all the
character and the culmination of
everything right yeah yeah yeah
long-term yeah and Thanos like the
biggest baddest mother yet Chuck Josh
Brolin biggest baddest dude I mean you
see the jaw line on that guy that guy
can take you out that guy's intimidating
without the gear just handsome
yeah great actor yeah evil person
that's Josh bro destroy the world
perfect Venice that's Josh bro I'll have
to go flying with the Thunderbirds let's
get you know what next time for Avengers
4 we're gonna put you in a harness and
we're gonna let you fly deal you're
gonna fly yes
every time I see you you're gonna have
to fly do you have some of that whiskey
will you have some some I'll have some I
don't know if we have a harness that
will fit you we might just have to wrap
you in duct tape and like pick you and
put you up there you go all right
everybody heard this Avengers for work
is flying here we go all right here we
go
oh yeah yeah you gonna have to see how
hard it is cuz you're gonna have to land
and that's gonna take you up 15 feet and
you're gonna have not land from 4000
skydiving once I had to land no no no no
you had a dude on your back you had an
old fat dude on your back
come on bro here we go no no no no no
this is just gonna win skydive and I had
this dude on my back weird situation but
I got your a counseling I'm good again
yeah but you come down you have to lay
and that's probably one of the harder
not on your face all right i'ma drop a
waiver we're gonna get video of you
signing away take your 15 feet you have
to lie can I wear like some headgear to
protect that would be even funnier yes
all right I'm done you bring the whiskey
I'll bring the we gotta bring my brother
Jack up the banners family yeah we're
gonna get you that little Frank Sinatra
I got you oh my god I'm crazy no not
that no trust me you have trust me trust
me ask our DJ how does he like flying
all right yeah or as as cheetah while he
likes all right yeah hates it is I don't
know I don't know I don't know it's not
a human element it's not something that
people should do
[Music]